the horses really do help you with
regression once you own a horse and you
out that's all your mind is always
having fun
my name is Shai here and I'm a concrete
I would
I first got on a horse after I turned 10
hey I was young so I was like I liked
that horse I thought it was cool
horses Irish temper just like us
me and shadow had to combine our tempers
and work together because she's the walk
wiry while I was running but though
people off and I just always just get
back on her just ahead of patience when
I ride people actually give me like
props and they actually be applauding me
the hood guys and everything maybe
actually can I ride you want to trade
people like it well the stable started
about 10 years ago it gave me something
to do something to keep the kids busy
with keep them occupied from running the
street get in trouble
and Southwest Philadelphia it's a lot of
senseless killing and I try to give kids
something to get away from stuff like
that and when they start learning with
the animals they kind of calm down
because they teach it and they learn it
me it helps them out a lot Hey filing
system you is crazy I don't lost a
brother uncle I lost a lot of friends
but when I work with the horses is like
a type of therapy I can have fun and not
worry about everything else that's going
on around ya if I would have never met
Malik instead of riding horses I
probably would have been doing stuff
that I was supposed to be doing getting
in trouble once you get to running and
having fun it seemed like all that is
forgotten
I'm a veteran
the Hoss is a veteran and I can't think
of a better place that he would be than
under my care
this horse Quincy is part of an elite
squad of horses in the military they're
called the caisson horses of the old
guard they participate in full honors
funerals at Arlington National Cemetery
over the course of their service each
horse walks in thousands of funerals
when horse is retired they need a place
to go Sulli old guard has introduced the
case on adoption project to ensure each
horse is given to their perfect forever
home to enjoy their well-earned
retirement and that's where George comes
in today he's taking Quincy home we're a
very patriotic family the flag flies on
the farm every day and it just became a
unique opportunity for another veteran
to retire on the farm
this is a long process there federal
property that's why they spend so much
time on making a decision to ensure that
these horses will be taken care of for
their lifespan I found out through my
daughter that the hast had some health
problems and what they call navicular
disease which is nerve damage on the
hoof and the farm is a rehab farm for
horses with foot problems and many
medical problems if she thought it would
be an ideal place for the Hoss to come
and live he has his dog tags just like
he did when he was in the service on his
halter only that the dog tag now reads
retired veteran
you
Quincy will spend the rest of his life
on the farm as my companion and as long
as he has a quality of life he will live
on the farm forever
you
riding blind horse that's a little
difference but to me it don't make much
difference he's pretty good friend he
just tickled to death to be rode
I think he knows that he's got eyes and
and he just jumped up and down and runs
and really likes to go out my name's
Rodrick Olson I'm soldier Grove
Wisconsin I have always had a few horses
matter of fact quite a few of them well
we got Jackson about 21 years ago about
ten years ago that we noticed it is
going blind and in fire we can find out
we've nothing we can do about it most
old horse dealers or firing ladies just
get rid of the horse but I figured I'm
in keeping I'd like to stick around a
while longer so if I went blind oh I
hope they keep me around awhile I didn't
figure he was useless he does everything
you want by the feel of the range he's a
little different riding than a regular
horse he's careful when he's running you
know he ain't sure where he feets gonna
go or what this front of him but he
didn't just quit because he got blind
he's trying to do things so he can take
care of himself he trust me to writing I
think he just figures it man I can see
now I got eyes I can do things that I
wanted to do for a long time he watches
it run he's fun for me to ride we go all
over the hills down the canyons in the
water everywhere that any other or can
go he does just find it but he must
trust me and well I trust him
always kind of a buddy anyhow being
friends with a horse that's a I don't
like the way it had been with me all my
life
God sent me here to be accountant
and the first thing in lady told me said
when you rode in the arena
you said everybody's eyes were on you
she said half of them wanted you to win
the other half don't give a damn whether
you win or not because of color your
skin but I'll always want to win I've
been a professional cowboy since 1959
dealing with racism back in the 50s and
six and now it's still kind of hard
people could see me at a rodeo and
because I was of a different color they
thought I was working for somebody
people want to know a lot of times why
did you want to be a terrible well I had
seen a lot of black cowboy was judged
improperly but the calf Ropin I knew
that I wasn't gonna be judged by a human
I was gonna be just by the clock the
clock was gonna determine whether I get
any money or not
right now all I do is put on Cowboys of
color rodeos Cowboys of color features
Indians blacks Hispanics and white
cowboy was also black Cowboys in the
history book is damn near for that very
many people don't even realize that New
Mexico was discovered by black men
Chicago was founded by black men I don't
care what color you are these are the
kind of things that we want young people
to know I have four boys they are all
professional Cowboys my grand daughter
Rachel Hearn this was her first big
rodeo so it's a way of life for us I'm
76 years old that's a pretty darn old
for cowboy it's in my blood I think the
day that I lay down and can't breathe
anymore
I'll still be looking for a rodeo a
rapper's carry fresh vegetables and
fruits around the city with horse-drawn
carts my grandma's been doing it all his
life he 80 something years old now I've
been doing it all my life and it's been
around 50 maybe 100 years before me
today in Baltimore you got markets
around but you got to have a vehicle to
get to them it's gonna cost them to get
there cause them to get back and so it's
beneficial to a lot of people for their
Abraham's to be on the street Drive look
up every morning
pull my wagon up I get all the fruit
together and design it up make it look
nice and then I take the bus and put
them in the wagon I start on my day you
mostly call out what you got on your
wagon we don't use an app open a no
pictures up when you come up and you see
I ugly person just waiting at the door
for you to come through and they get a
load list that's the one who film but
they depend on us and we try to be there
for a rabbit's for like maybe a BRABUS
would like
we can't they let us and I want them to
be able to see that selling drugs ain't
the only way to make money this is we
keep me out of trouble this is will feed
my families with pet food on the table
pay the bills paid guests this is one of
the the oldest things in the city I
still going right now this is history
when I was a little kid it was nothing
for me to turn the corner see a rapper
one right behind another sometimes if we
don't get a lot of people behind us and
they suppose they read in business it
might eventually die out my dream is to
see last forever to the day I shut my
eyes for good